it has happened again another totally
fake FoxNews expert who just so happens
to be pro Trump and Fox News has a long
history of being so desperate to push a
particular narrative that they put on
trolls they put on liars who were
willing to say whatever it is that Fox
News wants said as a reminder a few
examples back in 2012 there was this
fake former Obama supporter max rice who
pranked his way onto Fox News and was
interviewed by gretchen carlson we
interviewed him to figure out how he did
it
hilarious clip check it out on our
YouTube channel February of this year
Neal's built was interviewed on Fox News
as an imaginary Swedish defense adviser
turns out that those credentials were
also totally fake and just a few months
ago in July Jesse Watters trolled was
trolled by a fake aunt Eva activist
desperate to make the left seem violent
Jesse Watters interviewed a guy who was
actually kind of a known prankster okay
so it has happened again Fox News ran a
story a few days ago about a decorated
heroic patriotic Vietnam War Navy SEAL
who just loves Trump and Trump is so
great and it turns out it was all fake
the guy is a liar and Fox News fell for
it again it's 72 year old John Garofalo
who was presented as a decorated Vietnam
veteran from a Navy SEAL team who
received two Purple Hearts and several
dozen other medals for his service and
none of it was true here's a clip of
this guy on Fox News Garofalo is used to
working under pressure the Vietnam War
veteran served seven years as a member
of the nation's first Navy SEAL team he
was awarded 22 commendations including
two Purple Hearts you are a hero of the
like most here I just like to hear it
here was other ones that didn't come up
uh-huh actual Navy SEALs figured out
that this guy's a liar he never served
in Vietnam he was never a Navy SEAL he
served in the name of Navy from 1963 to
67 according to records that the Navy
Times
and he admitted eventually that yes he
has been lying about being a Vietnam
veteran and a Navy SEAL for years
explaining that quote it got bigger and
bigger what I did I'm ashamed of and I
didn't mean to cause so much disgrace to
the seals Fox News has sort of issued a
correction and this is a classic case of
stolen valor which is actually illegal
there's a the Stolen Valor Act of 2013
makes it a federal crime to claim to
have received certain military awards
and the Purple Heart among many others
are on that list and you know the
biggest example of these dudes who just
have a totally fake background that are
championed by the right this isn't a
military example but it's a big one Joe
the Plumber remember Joe the Plumber
whose name wasn't actually Joe it was
Samuel Wurzelbacher he ended up not even
being a licensed plumber he became this
sort of authoritative voice in favor of
John McCain and against Barack Obama
during the 2008 election and one of his
big things was I'm about to buy a
business that makes over $250,000 a year
so I would be really impacted by
President Obama's tax plan turns out the
guy didn't make over $250,000 a year he
was never actually a licensed plumber
and again no one has apologized for that
it's not stolen valor of the military
kind but these right-wing media outlets
will pick up on whoever will further the
narrative that they're trying to push
and they become total useful idiots and
useful idiot we could apply it to more
than just the people that are used you
you could also argue that even the media
outlets that fall for this stuff are the
useful idiots for the broader right-wing
elected official candidate or movement
or whatever the case may be how many
times is Fox News going to fall for this
nonsense it seems like it's going to be
many more that's for sure